the mid and post credit scene for
spider-man fire from home were both
fantastic but many fans were shocked and
disappointed that we didn't see anything
about the introduction of the sinister
six or Oscorp how's it going everybody
it's warrant real quick there will be no
spoilers for spider-man fire from home
in this video so if you have not seen it
don't worry
there were many leaks and reports before
spider-man far from home came out that
said the post-credits scene was going to
introduce the sinister six and Norman
Osborn and Oscorp now obviously this did
not happen the mid and post credits
scenes had nothing to do with the
sinister six or Oscorp however according
to new reports the original post-credit
scene was supposed to be the sinister
six according to the credible and
verified reddit user the marvel scoop
master the original post-credit scene
for spider-man far from home was this
Mysterio is in a big building looking
over the city at night I'm just being
defeated by spider-man and then in the
room with him was shocker vulture
scorpion and chameleon and then at the
end of the post-credits scene Norman
Osborn would enter the room according to
the redditor the Marvel scoop master
this scene was shot the visual effects
were complete and ready to go but for
some reasons director John Watts decided
to scrap it now it makes sense that this
scene was shot and completed because
when the pre-screening for spider-man
far from home came out a few weeks
before the actual movie hit theaters
there were many reports from people
including grace Randolph at beyond the
trailer who said that Norman Osborn was
about to be introduced into the MCU now
if you have seen spider-man far from
home you know that this did not happen
so why were there reports after the
pre-screening of spider-man far from
home from people saying that Norman
Osborn is going to be introduced into
the MCU in a couple of weeks perhaps
this original post-credit scene for
spider-man far from home was shown
during the pre-screening now it's
unclear why director John Watts would
change the post-credits scene to what it
was it seems like the sinister six has
been teased for a long time now in fact
many people thought that scorpion and
vulture were going to be in spider-man
far from home but they weren't perhaps
John Watts is planning to introduce the
sinister six and spider-man 3 and this
makes sense considering the mid-credits
scene for spider-man far from home it
wouldn't really be that hard for Norman
and the rest of the sinister six to
track spider-man down it also goes along
with the reports that daredevil Deadpool
or venom could be introduced in
spider-man 3 as well and the reason they
may introduce one of these characters is
to help Peter Parker take on the
sinister six one of the reasons that
director Jon Watts could have chose to
not put this in the post-credits scene
for spider-man far from home was that
Kevin Feige said that we won't be
hearing anything about phase four until
after spider-man far from home and
teasing Norman Osborn would definitely
be a big reveal of phase four so perhaps
that's why Jon Watts decided to change
the post-credits scene now even though
there were many reports about this
original post-credit scene in spider-man
far from home you should still take this
with a grain of salt because it is still
a leak but the way everything has been
set up it does seem like Marvel could be
ready to introduce the sinister six and
spider-man 3 so be sure to let me know
your thoughts about this would you have
preferred this post-credit scene to the
ones that we got and would you be
excited for the sinister six to be
introduced in spider-man 3 let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
also be sure to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway I'm picking three
new winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers and also be sure to
subscribe to my channel if you'd like to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof